creature has competition on the eleventh
day of the eleventh moon of the eleventh
year a gateway will open it becomes
beings unlike mortal eyes of six eleven
eleven eleven is a gimmick movie that's
what I'm gonna call it a gimmick movie
because that's what it is it's a gimmick
movie that's all it is it's a gimmick
movie it's about November 11th 2011 and
a man who seems to suddenly get the idea
that the world is going to come to an
end on that day weird things happen at
11:00 11:00 at night he almost dies in a
car crash at 11:11 a.m. he wakes up from
dreams at 11:11 a.m. he sees 11:11
everywhere and he's positive the world's
gonna come to end on 11/11/11 this
movies directed by the mastermind behind
saw two three and four movies I have not
seen but I have heard are pretty bad boy
that is a great filmmaker 11 that I I
only want to keep saying the title cuz
so this is honestly this is one of the
worst movies there
I'm in Spain what serious yeah my
brother my father live here that's dying
I just thought you should know this is a
horrible film wow man it's trying to be
suspenseful and it's trying to be scary
it's trying to be significant in some
way it's trying to be creepy it does
none of those things seriously this
movie is so awful I laughed more at some
of the scares in this movie than I did
it some comedies this year there's even
one moment where I laughed so hard that
for so long that I had to like catch my
breath because there was a scare where
the god this guy like turns around and
there's like this creature in the corner
and it just lifts up its hands and make
some like gesture it was the funniest
thing I have seen in a while
well you're not scared I got a bed every
night per animal wake up more afraid
with God I know doesn't exist to run me
down by car and the day it finally
happens I walk away without a scratch it
wasn't your time written and directed by
the same guy he wrote this movie and he
directed it and some idiot somewhere
said let's make that piece of garbage
that's gonna be a good big old head not
only is this movie irrelevant today
because of how horrible it is but it
will be even more irrelevant in the
future when November 11th 2011 passes
and this movie suddenly has nothing
anymore the whole point of this movie is
be scared of that date as soon as that
date happens this Friday after that this
movie will have virtually no relevance
at all everyone will watch this movie
and think wow not only this is a
horrible movie but this this has nothing
anymore and that's why I say it's a
make movie all it is is Wow some studio
guy was like hey it's gonna be November
11 2011 we should do some crazy movie I
want to ask you a question
you ever see a number reappearing in
your life over and over again 11 10 11
11 I was wearing that blooms in my car
accident and it even seems like the
director has an idea of how to do
something somewhere in the back of his
brain there's an idea of how to make a
movie but somehow there's some sort of
switch inside that's not connecting with
his hands and the rest of his brain to
be able to actually do it correctly I am
so mad when I see this when I see people
continuously given opportunities in
Hollywood to be filmmakers and they just
suck this movie is a gimmick it's not
scary it's actually hilariously unscary
the script is awful the ending which I
in case someone once you see this movie
like legitimately not because they want
to see it just because I want to see how
bad is they actually are excited for
this movie I won't spoil the horrible
awful ending that puts everything that
happens before it completely void and
makes the entire film make absolutely no
sense at all this is a horrible evasion
11-11-11 gets an F it's an awful film
awful awful it's so bad who's that here
and since you will want to know if I
like it less or more than creature I'm
pretty sure creatures a little bit worse
but not by much wow this is an old movie
if you like this review you can
subscribe to my channel and get steppen
eyes